i'm not a clubber but i went clubbing
he's a clever it turns out
i want to unpack this more what was
yours on monday night what did you wear
to the club oh i look good no i went to
i bet you diesel i know
i got a whole diesel because i have
there's some
yeah affliction shirt yeah the whole
thing my vagina just ate itself
right right so then i would and i would
powder and i would come to these cloves
and i would dance right
oh my god he walks in dancing already
yeah he walks in dancing
so i would go on monday night there was
a place called joseph's of course you'd
go to a place called jose it was on
monday nights it was over there on uh
near vine vine and it was a hot spot
monday nights everyone hunt
okay shut the [ __ ] up dog
and so i was at the common store and
bonnie goes you can get us into clubs
you guys want to go to joseph's right
now i got a guy andrew
right and came with us okay
we had a great night you guys are so
cool yeah yeah but immediately after he
got
as a riding gig too yeah and to be
honest
and then he saw me a couple years after
that and he said what are you doing here
and it really hurt my feelings
interesting it
it when things like that happen it
devastates me
because it's like we went clubbing i got
you into this
i got you into this thing okay so are
people obligated to like you
so are people let's say you guys hung
out right he didn't like your vibe your
codes didn't match
and then he decided for himself hey i
don't like bobby lee i don't know what
it is about him
but i'm not going to fake it or try to
be nice all right joe rogan and i
joe rogan and i aren't best friends
right yeah
i see when i see joe we he we hug we say
i love you buddy i love you man i mean
there's
respect there i like him a lot i really
do i think he's great
but we're not like i don't go to his
house and barbecue i don't go hunting
with him
yeah right but a long time ago when i
was living in san diego
and he was headlining the la jolla
comedy store we went to a strip club and
we almost died
i unpacked that we almost died at the
strip club
okay because this man with tattoos on
his face
right approached us like i said
something to this girl like hey baby
you got a nice ass you did yeah there
you go and this guy with that tattoo on
his face
what'd you say bro and then joe and he
was with a couple of other guys
i think jimmy schubert was there and we
stood up and then
he turned to his friend and goes hey bro
let's go to the car to get a gun or
something
who did the guy with a tattoo yeah
tattoo phase and then joe rogan goes
let's get out of here
right and i go i call jerome and a [ __ ]
i go eat [ __ ] you know he talks about
this on stage yeah they get [ __ ]
they're not gonna do nothing
right and we almost died okay come out
with guns
no but we could have died damn who knows
but we had that experience together okay
so so what i'm saying is that
joe will always bring that experience up
it's
positive and negative right it's when i
first met him
but it is something that happened and
there's a bond there it's like two
people at
war together so when you were when you
went out with
were you still drinking no you're sober
my question is something must have
happened for him to be like you know
what i [ __ ] don't like that guy
and i'm not going to fake it he doesn't
respect he there there's people
i think we should ask him no no there
are people out there i'm going to be
real
there are people out there i'll say
right now i'm going to tell you right
now yeah
there's a casting director